calling it art we don't give it space to
be preserved this is the other big
challenge of our times is you the
economic machinery is just choking
people and it's making it so that I
can't even afford time on love on
friends on passions on nature editions
passing down tradition traditions asleep
has taken the biggest toll which
directly affects our physiology and our
moment-to-moment health so we're
literally deteriorating when we sleep
for six hours and stuff Oh choking us
it's choking us people can't do
something that's so deeply important is
being able to fall in love to experience
a deep profound love to have a so robust
social network with five or ten really
good friends cooking the meals growing
food experiencing all these things has
taken a huge backseat to the fact that I
got a rod at work all day if you're in
survival mode there's not time for this
stuff right here literally I mean and
I'm speaking live from a great
experience if I gotta choose between
doing laundry and feeding myself and
doing this paper and I think that's
where we are there is not enough time to
enjoy life to build community if you
can't build community how can I see
myself in another person's experience if
I can't talk to someone how do I pass
down to pass down these traditions if I
don't have time to if I'm working ten
jobs how do I have time to go and see
this great artistic space right I mean
what do you do with that when you're in
hustle mode all the time yeah